one problem 21 which product is
equivalent to 4x squared minus 16 over 2
minus X so let's see if we can simplify
this a little bit 4x squared minus 16 if
we were to factor out a 4 that's the
same thing as 4 times x squared minus 4
right that's 4x squared minus 16 all of
that over 2 minus X and then x squared
minus 4 that's that same pattern that
keeps showing up a squared minus B
squared right so that numerator becomes
4 times X plus 2 times X minus 2 right a
plus B times a minus B and then the
denominator let's think about it this
has 2 minus X and we have an X minus 2
here but what if we were a what if we
were to factor out a negative 1 from
this what happens if you factor out a
negative 1 then the negative X becomes a
positive X and then the positive 2
becomes a minus 2 and I did that just so
just to show you that a negative if you
divide this by or multiply by a negative
1 you just switch the order 2 minus X
becomes X minus 2 which is a good thing
to recognize because we have an X minus
2 in the numerator 2 so this will cancel
out with that if we assume that X cannot
equal that X does not ever equal 2
because X equaling 2 would make this and
an undefined statement because you can't
divide by 0 but if we make that
assumption we could cancel those out and
then we have 4 divided by negative 1 is
minus 4 times X plus 2 and that is
choice D choice D next question
22 I like this cutting and pasting of
the actual question it makes it makes it
fun so they want us to I just want don't
want it to slow down my computer too
much I start sound like I'm I sound like
I'm melting when that happens
so that's our problem I didn't write the
choices down all right let's see what we
could do so they have it's you know x
squared plus 4x times let me write this
so x squared plus 4x over X plus 3 times
x squared minus 9 all of that over x
squared plus X minus 12 and you might
say oh my god to multiply these using
algebraic multiplication would take
forever and then I have to factor it and
simplify it and the trick here is to
factor and simplify it before you do any
multiplication so let's simplify each of
these expressions and cancel out as much
as possible so here we can just factor
out an X so this just becomes x times X
plus 4 all right this is a squared minus
B squared so this becomes X plus 3 times
X minus 3 did that you can't do much
let's think about this one what two
numbers add up to a 1 write a 1 X and
when you sub and you multiply them you
get a minus 12 so let's see see if you
got a X plus 4 times X minus 3 that
should work 4 minus 3 is 1 4 times minus
3 is minus well so that works all right
now we're ready to cancel and you could
you could view this so this let me I'll
you know normally I would just start
canceling but I just want to make the
point home that this so this is equal to
x times X plus 4 times these X plus 3
times X minus 3 all of that all of that
over X plus 3 X plus 3 times X plus 4
times X minus 3 right and now we can
cancel we have an X minus 3 X minus 3 X
plus 4 X plus 4 X plus 3 X plus 10 all
were left is with an X so all of this
fancy expression all that equals is an X
and that's choice B whatever my next
problem
image clear image invert colors there
you go
all right let me see if I have to copy
and paste this one where was I why not
another one were there they're trying to
get us get the simplest form so I copied
it and go back to my let me paste it
alright I hope you can read this so what
is the simplest form of this expression
here I'll rewrite it 5 X to the 3rd Y
plus 20 x squared y squared plus 20x why
isn't everything divided by 5 X Y so 5 X
Y actually goes into every one of these
terms right so let's just get rid of the
5s if we divide the numerator the
denominator well actually let's just
divide the numerator and denominator by
5 X Y so what's 5 X to the 3rd Y divided
by 5 X Y well 5 divided by 5 I'll do it
in magenta 5 divided by 5 is 1 so we
don't write that X to the 3rd divided by
X is x squared Y divided by Y is 1 so
this term divided by this term reduces
to that easy enough next 1 plus 20
divided by 5 is 4 x squared divided by X
is X Y squared divided by Y is y did the
second term let's do the third term 20
divided by 5 is 4 X divided by X is 1 Y
we don't so we'd have to write it Y the
third divided by Y is y squared Y
squared and what we have here is this
simplified but that doesn't look like
anything here so my guess is that this
is probably one of these this is the
square of something and let's see if we
could factor this this would be X so
what two numbers when I add them become
4 X Y and when I multiply them or what
what number when I multiply it times X
is equal to half of this right that's
another way to think about it and when I
square it is equal to 4 y squared well
that's just plus 2 y squared and if that
didn't make a lot of sense multiply this
out and and you
you'll get this answer and when you look
at the choices you should just say okay
I know I know that this choice and this
choice I mean that littles look nothing
like that and you say oh well maybe this
is one of these choices right but you
have a 4y squared here this one has no y
at all in it so you can even just use
deductive reasoning to say oh the choice
must be X plus 2 y squared next problem
okay this one I'm definitely going to
copy and paste because if they have a
they have a big image all right let me
see if I can do it it's makes it a lot
easier than having to draw it myself all
right if I equals the square root of
negative 1 which well if you didn't know
it that's what I is defined as and I had
gone many videos about them the magic of
I and II and Pi which point shows the
location of five minus two I on the
plane so this is the real the x-axis is
the real axis you take the real part
which is five so you go one two three
four five so that's the real part and
then the y axis is the imaginary axis
you take the imaginary part minus 2i
minus two right so you go down to in the
I direction and you're at point D which
is choice D fair enough the problem that
had a lot of graphics but was an
unusually simple next problem
next problem okay now they're giving us
a whole parade of imaginary number of
questions so this one I don't have to
cut copy and paste they say if I is
equal to the square root of negative 1
which is a definition that we've all
learned what is the value of I of I to
the fourth well let's just go back from
you know let's say you've never seen I
before in your life and let's think
about if I is equal to negative 1 sorry
this is negative 1 I know that negative
looks like it got messed up let's square
both sides of this equation I squared
will be equal to negative 1 now let's
square both sides of this equation
right I squared squared is equal to
negative 1 squared
well I squared squared is just I to the
4th right 2 times 2 is equal to negative
1 squared which is just equal to 1
and we're done that's choice C choice C
all right now they have another
imaginary graph so let me just let me
just copy and paste this graph I'll go
here there you go I just didn't have to
erase what I had before and the question
they asked us which of the following
complex numbers is represented by the
point on the graph below so we just have
figure out the real and the imaginary
parts so what's the real part this
coordinate its real part is 3 so it's
real part is 3 and it's imaginary part
is minus 4 right there - minus 4 so it's
3 and it's imaginary part minus 4 in the
imaginary direction and we're done three
months 4i that's choice C choice C and
then I'm almost out of time I'll see you
in the next video